hello
welcome
unsubscriptions
all of these subjects that we
talk about on simulation are again
they are the different faces
of the same mountain
all the different paths to the
one end and so we're showing
all of these different aspects and you
draw
parts from the videos and add them to
your web
of being that
enables you to pierce the veil and
self-realize and god realize and then
have an effortless action of wu way
as you channel the absolute highest
in complete surrender and service to
the unfolding of this
simply this the now
what is happening simply now
but we've lost complete awe
for the now
i also spent such a massive chunk
of my life the first 28 years
in complete loss of awe
for just simply now
and i dedicated myself five years
straight
relentlessly to seeking truth and i
pierced the veil
self-realized about a month ago
and now
it's all about complete surrender
to that one infinite truth
a lot of non-duality teaches
the simple unsubscribing
there are matrix subscriptions
that are all over
saturating our webs of existence
and there's all the simultaneity that we
have to hold while we even do this
conversation
first of all nonduality literally
doesn't teach
anything it just literally means to be
as everything is perfect
indescribable absolute perfection on the
most transcendent level
okay now on another layer of it we say
that okay non-duality is
about nons about unsubscribing
it's about not falling into the traps
and the temptations of the matrix
subscription so that you can pierce the
veil and self-realize more optimally
so there's all these different layers
all right let's go through the
unsubscriptions
which can also be called matrix
subscriptions
these are all matrix subscriptions that
we are unsubscribing from
and this is why the majority
of people fall into the illusions of
these matrix subscriptions
they are uninvestigated beliefs
beliefs of ego beliefs of time beliefs
of polarization
beliefs of seeking beliefs of fast
everything
all right let's start with ego
the ego is a contraction the ego
is a contracted separate entity
that is constantly seeking happiness
outside of itself
i will acquire said objects and
experiences
and then i will be happy that is the
drum
that the ego beats
so it's a contracted identity
like an onion with all of these layers
it doesn't understand itself as the i am
pure bear empty awareness of the ocean
that is infinite that is experiencing
the waves it doesn't understand that
and so it's associated with all these
layers of identity
and it believes it is a completely
separate individual entity
by itself never has tasted the ocean
whatsoever
and that contracted egoic separate
entity
it has so much fear it
wants to acquire in order to be
safe it's fallen to the greatest
illusion
of fear
now if we imagine that contracted egoic
separate entity like a sugar cube
what happens gradually or suddenly
depending on if the
process of self-realization is taken
quite
seriously and optimally then there can
be
more direct piercings of the veil and
self-realization god realization
is that that sugar cube can either
slowly or quickly and preferably quickly
which is what
this is all about these transmissions
are all about
speeding up the process again on the
most transcendent non-do level
everything's already perfect there is
literally no need to speed anything up
just be effortless effortless
being presence simply this
now and then if you go another layer
in you can see that there is something
to do
there's a process called
self-realization that will literally
cause me to stop egoically like a
separate entity
seeking happiness outside of myself and
rather
recognize that the well of honey
is just inside of me and it's covered by
a rock
so that contracted egoic separate entity
is like a sugar cube
that will either gradually or suddenly
preferably suddenly dissolve
itself it will relax
and you'll usually be met with some sort
of a release
and some sort of an expansion
and that sugar cube dissolves into the
infinitude of consciousness into the
infinity of awareness
this is what is eternal that is what is
meant by enlightenment
is when that contracted separate entity
dissolves into the infinite
consciousness into the very i
am-ness that is eternal it has been here
it will keep being here it is
very simply put it is the blank
paper it is the blank paper that has
eternally been
colored by different words and the words
are thoughts feelings emotions beliefs
experiences objects another analogy is
the ocean
you recognize yourself as the ocean
that is experiencing waves
so you recognize that juxtaposition when
the egoic contracted
entity of the sugar cube dissolves into
infinite consciousness
it recognizes itself as the ocean that
is
experiencing the different modulations
of waves
of experiences and it becomes better and
better over time
at surfing riding the crest
of the wave being in the now
simply this
along with that process the second one
time also dissolves
all of the illusion of time it
completely dissolves
i am born i die
this infinite eternal awareness does not
birth and it does not die
it is always here it's always
now being colored
infinitely differently and that's the
creative component
so the illusion of time and the illusion
of
infinity being finite being a finite
separate biological creature completely
dissolves
again we talk about this a lot on the
program but the middle path or the
middle way or the tantric
path or the goldilocks zone it has a lot
to do with your ability to ebb
and flow between the
physical and the absolute in a sense
it enables you to flow between the
complete illusion of time and completely
hold that
always while also when somebody says
will you meet me here
at three o'clock that you actually show
up at three o'clock so you know
how to sahaja samadhi which is when you
weave the tantric path your
self-realization into the social fabric
that's the ultimate middle path
middleway
expression of enlightenment is to be
that fluid joseph in the code of many
colors that
most synthesis style expression of
infinity where you can ebb and flow to
all different
levels of consciousness that is piercing
the veil
of reality
recognizing its oceanic infinitude
dissolving the egoic
sugar cube of the separate entity
and we must in order to actually get to
these
states of self-realization the most
important thing that you can do is to
recognize the input stream
i've been talking about this through
high level perception and through so
much
of what my work is high
amount of vigilance with the input
stream
everything is so salient
that comes in and that affects you all
of the coloration is so important
and so in a sense again at the most
transcendent perspective it's the oh
it's the absolute surrender to the
perfection that it already is
yes and then also another layer of it is
that in order to actually pierce the
veil and self-realize
the level of discernment with the input
stream is critical
are you watching polarization propaganda
because if you are that is literally all
about
fear it is all about separation distance
yourself
wisely and gracefully distance yourself
do not be a martyr
do not run around yelling at other egoic
separate entities that
are contracted and that are watching
polarization propaganda saying you
should not watch that
don't do that don't be a martyr be
graceful and be wise and just distance
yourself
from the polarization propaganda
that 24 7 news cycle of mass
media garbage has so many perverse
incentives associated in its
archaic infrastructures that are
indoctrinating
our child like infinity into egoic
separate contracted entities that is
slowly dissolving to the decentralized
infrastructures that are being born
today
and that's what we see with media that's
what we see
with blockchains cryptocurrencies
decentralization
don't fall for the polarization between
the politics domestically in the u.s or
in the geopolitical sense between the
greatest economies on the planet
don't fall for the polarization
firmly anchor unity consciousness
god consciousness
again their
happiness seeking it externally
is
as an egoic separate entity
is the parable of the prodigal son
that
as we go outward first
inevitably no matter what we hit a
breaking point in recognizing that
happiness
cannot be found externally and that
eventually
we turn inward and we realize
that the well of honey is
under the rock
if you are to seek seek inward
seek inward all these different
paths on the faces of the mountain that
are
pointing to the one truth
all of the perennial wisdoms focus
inward
on those perennial wisdoms and hang
those up in your latticework in your
worldview in your essence
color your awareness or your
consciousness color
the infinite awareness
consciousness with the words
that maximize
your ability to seek
inward to self-realize to pierce that
veil
because when you're seeking fame money
clout materialism
when you're seeking all of those things
externally
you are hitting breaking points
where you are
not living from a place of 24 7 bliss
you're living in a place that's giving
you five minutes of bliss per
day the 24 7 bliss
only comes from self-realization you
realize your own
godness you realize your own infinitude
you realize
your own sourceness your own i am-ness
that is infinite that is eternal and
that is being colored by
experience you recognize you are the
ocean we've always been the ocean this
is what we do this is what non-duality
does
it does this creative expression game
again on the input stream unsubscribe
from fast food
fast sex fast information and fast high
fructose corn syrup
unsubscribe from all of that
it's quite common sense
at this point
to think that having a one-night stand
does not
energetically affect me is
absolute insanity to think that
me consuming fast food
animal that has been under only
stress secreting only the hormone
cortisol
for days and days on end and then me
consuming that is not affecting me
is crazy it's insanity same thing with
the high fructose corn syrup
you can't eat 40 grams of sugar in a
soft drink
and then think that that's not affecting
you horribly
and same thing with information as well
that
it's common sense now that it does
require a more nuanced
and slowed down process of analyzing
many different sources of information in
order to be able to even have
a synthesis to have a joseph in the code
of many colors perspective
on the complex issues yet at the same
time again from a very transcendent
non-dual perspective
it is just simply this happening
just this now-ness
that is it and there's nothing to do
and so there's all these different
layers of simultaneity
and so we'll be unpacking that in our
next video
and also unsubscribe from bars from
clubs from sports from festivals
if you're going out and playing sports
and you're doing that from a place of
oceanic
i am-ness from a place of knowingness
from a place of
self-realization and you're playing
sports to keep up on your health
fantastic that's your expression of
infinity it's incredible now
if you're going to bars and clubs and
festivals
to escape because you want to drink
alcohol because you think that's going
to make you happy
because you think you might find
somebody that you absolutely
might fall in love with that's going to
make you happy
or that you want to dance at a club and
have a one-night stand
again you can take it from an
enlightened perspective as well
maybe you want to go and actually dance
and express yourself and that's the way
that
the wind is moving you but you recognize
you're the ocean
undergoing that experience you are not a
contracted separate egoic entity
that is going into a club to hang out
with other contracted separate egoic
entities that are all seeking for
happiness outside of themselves
and very similarly with festivals and we
can also include
the peak experience chasing there as
well i will
seek happiness on this three-day music
festival
i will seek happiness by traveling to a
different country around the world
i will seek happiness by taking in
entheogens
i will seek happiness through these
external means now all these things can
serve you if you go
to greece for a couple weeks and you
immerse yourself
in the neoplatonism you
might actually have a pretty serious
upgrade in your conceptual frameworks
that enable you
to be able to self-realize and
similarly if you take a heroic dose of
psilocybin
you may actually commune with
non-duality
and then aim to re-baseline yourself to
that oceanic infinitude
so now you know that there's a lot of
unsubscriptions that have to happen
there's a lot of unsubscribing that has
to happen
in order to self-realize the last
five years for me of relentlessly
persistently full-time job seeking
truth
had so many unsubscriptions
so many sacrifices but that's what
enables you to pierce the veil
that's what enables you to pierce the
veil
and there's very simple ways to start
all of you have feeds you all have your
feeds that you browse
last year in 2020 i literally went on
a near-year-long digital detox
so that i could actually be able to hone
in on all of the
perennial wisdoms across the traditions
so that i could have
the satori that happened about a month
ago that occurred
and now alan sakhyan's dissolved atlas
is dissolved it is literally just
non-duality now
the simple thing you can do is along
with these different
principles in adding those
adding the principles that are going to
help you self-realize and unsubscribing
from the principles that don't help you
self-realize in this case all of your
feeds your feeds have a bunch of people
that you follow
that promulgate a lot of the concepts of
ego of separation of fear of contracted
identities and entities of infinity of
polarization
of mass media garbage of seeking money
fame materials on fast food sex
information
high fructose corn syrup all types of go
and unfollow those accounts
unfollow those accounts your input
stream
is so valuable be vigilant about your
input stream
all you have to do is go once and
unfollow
all of the accounts that no longer serve
your self-realization
and boom you've done a massive
accelerating step
in cleansing out what is the input
stream that comes in
to help you pierce the veil
again on a very most transcendent
level everything is already perfect
that is what the non-dual teaching is
this is perfect
it is just this that is happening
right now and to be able to relax
into the infinitude of this nowness
is it
and to be completely surrendered to that
infinite intelligence
is it that is it
on another layer with true simultaneity
this
discernment with unsubscribing is
crucial
unsubscribe to all of these things that
we mentioned on the show
and subscribe to only what serves
you piercing the veil to self
realize
i love you thank you for tuning in like
the video if it brought you value
subscribe if you haven't already
leave us a comment below where you're at
in this process we'd love to hear from
you
share the video with people that you
know that it would positively influence
that's all much love
thank you